y pues no sé ustedes pero yo estoy
esperando con ansias el final de este
problema y supongo que ustedes estarán
igual que yo y realmente estamos en la
recta final simplemente tenemos que
simplificar esta expresión en rosa que
obtuvimos en el último vídeo para
obtener los posibles valores de x así
que vamos a simplificar primero el
radical es decir todo lo que está dentro
de nuestra raíz cuadrada y empecemos con
este término tenemos la raíz de tres
menos dos al cuadrado y si elevamos al
cuadrado es el cuadrado del primero que
es tres verdad el cuadrado de la raíz
cuadrada pues es como no haberle hecho
nada verdad
dogmas dos veces el producto de ellos
que es 2 x menos 2 es menos 4 x raíz de
3 es menos 4 raíz de 3 y luego sumarle
el cuadrado de 2 que es 4 más 4 muy bien
y luego restamos 4 y hay que efectuar
este producto verdad de este con este
así que vamos a multiplicar y tenemos
raíz de 3 x raíz de 3 3
verdad luego a raíz de 3 x 1 es raíz de
3 menos dos por la raíz de tres es menos
dos veces la raíz de tres y menos dos
por uno es menos 2 muy bien vamos a
seguir simplificando este problema de
verdad nos está causando problemas valga
la redundancia pero bueno tenemos tres
más cuatro son siete verdad éste y éste
y le restamos cuatro raíz de tres y
luego menos cuatro por tres es menos 12
menos 4 por raíz de 3 es ok
hagamos algo antes mejor
si nosotros simplificamos aquí tenemos 3
y menos 2 estos 2 nos dan un 1 y luego
tenemos raíz de 3 menos dos veces la
raíz de 3
esto me da menos la raíz de 3 así que si
yo hago la multiplicación menos 4 por 1
es menos 4 y menos 4 por menos la raíz
de 3 es más cuatro veces la raíz de 3 y
gracias a dios ahora si ya tenemos algo
que se puede cancelar al fin y que nos
simplifica un poco la vida y de hecho
nos queda 7 menos 4 y esto solo es un 3
muy bien entonces vamos a ver
tenemos que nuestros valores x pueden
ser 22 menos la raíz de 3 es verdad
bueno nuestros x son dos menos la raíz
de tres más o menos lo que estaba dentro
de la raíz que simplemente fue 3
entonces tenemos la raíz de 3 ya de
abajo multiplicamos esto y nos queda dos
veces la raíz de 3 y 2 x menos 2 es
menos 4 muy bien entonces tenemos dos
posibles respuestas
la primera digamos que pasa si tomamos
el más si tomamos el más tenemos dos
menos raíz de tres más raíz de tres sólo
nos da 12 y lo dividimos entre dos veces
la raíz de 3 menos 4 que de hecho como
hay un factor 2 tanto arriba como abajo
lo podemos dividir arriba y abajo entre
2 y nos queda 1 entre la raíz de 3 menos
2 muy bien y pues ahora lo que podemos
intentar hacer es racionalizar el el
resultado es decir multiplicamos por
el conjugado de este que no es otra cosa
más que cambiarle el signo verdad de
esta forma tenemos una diferencia de
cuadra bueno vamos a tener una
diferencia de cuadrados ahora para que
esto no se altere de dvd a ver lo mismo
abajo que arriba y entonces arriba nos
queda uno por raíz de tres más dos es
raíz de tres más dos y abajo tengo
binomios conjugados y esto nos da el
cuadrado del primero que es 3 y le
restamos el cuadrado del segundo que es
2 al cuadrado es 4 entonces 3 menos 4 es
menos 1 y simplemente nos queda menos la
raíz de tres más 2 muy bien entonces ya
al fin tenemos nuestra primera respuesta
vamos a ver qué pasa con la otra qué
pasa con la otra la otra sería y dos
menos raíz de tres menos raíz de tres
ahí tendríamos dos menos dos veces la
raíz de tres entre dos veces la raíz de
tres menos cuatro si quieren déjenme
ponerlo al revés
menos cuatro más dos veces la raíz de
tres muy bien y esto como lo podemos
hacer podemos dividir entre dos también
arriba y abajo verdad todo es divisible
entre dos y nos queda uno menos la raíz
de tres entre menos dos más la raíz de
tres y nuevamente vamos a racionalizar
el problema vamos a multiplicar por
menos dos menos la raíz de tres muy bien
y entonces que es lo que nos queda bueno
ok abajo es más fácil ahora sería menos
2 al cuadrado que es 4 menos la raíz de
3 al cuadrado que es menos 3 lo que sea
que eso sea va a ser 1 verdad 1 en el
denominador ahora vamos a hacer estas
operaciones 1 x menos 2 sería menos 21
por menos raíz de tres menos la raíz de
tres menos raíz de tres por menos dos es
más dos veces la raíz de tres y menos
raíz de tres por menos raíz de tres son
tres muy bien y tenemos tres menos dos y
es 1 y 2 raíz de tres menos raíz de 3 es
simplemente la raíz de 3 y esto ya es
nuestra segunda solución y no sé ustedes
pero esto yo creo que es muy emocionante
esto fue un problema increíblemente
enredado muy bien entonces podemos
concluir perfectamente quiénes son
en nuestras soluciones están dadas de la
siguiente forma x puede ser menos 2 más
la raíz de 3 que corresponde a este caso
o también puede ser el 1 más la raíz de
3 que es este otro caso verdad así que
vámonos arriba para revisar nuestras
respuestas posibles y en principio 1
pues podría estar bien tentado a decir
ah mira aquí está nuestra respuesta y
nuestra respuesta ve y nos dicen que
allí pueden ser varios valores de x los
que pueden ser ciertos pero todavía no
hemos terminado y hay que tener mucho
cuidado ya que también recordar el
contexto por ejemplo el valor a no
funciona porque porque estamos hablando
de medidas de un triángulo verdad
longitudes de sus segmentos y nos dicen
que dos por este valor x más uno es el
lado c eso quiere decir que sea al menos
debe ser positivo muy bien y si nosotros
multiplicamos esto por 2
aquí tendrían raíz de 3 es 1 punto y
cachito entonces tendríamos 2 más 1
punto y cachito es 3 punto y cachito con
menos y al multiplicarlo por 2 sería
menos 6 punto de cachito que al sumarle
1 es menos 5 punto cachito y es negativo
ese es el punto entonces esta solución
la a no es válida porque no tiene
sentido en el problema la única
respuesta correcta es la b es la b así
que bueno este fue un problema bastante
bastante enredado no fue nada fuera del
otro mundo no fue algo que necesitábamos
una idea genial simplemente
necesitábamos mucho orden y muchas
herramientas de álgebra de polinomios y
demás en fin si alguien sabe una forma
más rápida de hacerlo hágamelo saber